hi I'm dream and this is the wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
I like to say that I'm six foot two
did dream put the mask back on kind of
it just depends I want to make sure that
I still have the mask I love the mask
it's great and what it stands for is
amazing but if I'm just being dream or
I'm you know I want to represent that
part of myself then I wear it so it's
kind of a 50 50. so I guess yes but no
what is dream SMP Minecraft SMP stands
for survival multiplayer and dream SMP
was a server that I started with a bunch
of my friends it just became a bigger
and bigger thing with like role play and
it was almost like people would watch it
kind of like an anime there was villains
and I was one of them is dream s p
scripted yes yes stream SMP was scripted
there was a lot of improv and there was
a lot of moments that happened and
sometimes we would plan out like all
right well we don't know exactly what
happened we want these key points we
have like this person is going to die
and we don't know exactly how yet and
then we just kind of go through and let
things go as they do so yes it was
scripted for sure did dream go to
college I've had HD so I always
struggled in school I was always like
from a pretty young age like I'm not
going to college my parents would always
be like well you need to do something if
you're not going to go to college so I
was like I'm going to get certifications
and try and learn so I learned to code I
got a bunch of like technical
certifications and so no I didn't but I
tried to make up for it in other ways is
dream a Minecraft God yes I am a
Minecraft God you should not mess with
me you will lose
where is dream Minecraft from I'm from
Orlando and dream Minecraft's from me
trying to say dream on and Inspire
yourself so when dream started playing
Minecraft around 2011 2010 there was a
server MCPVP that I I think was the
first server I ever played on which I
think opened in 2011 if I remember
correctly very very long time too long
how
fasted dream okay
beat Minecraft I think almost anyone
could be Minecraft in four hours they
put enough like practice and into it but
it's a little harder when you have
people chasing you down or something
I've beaten it in you know 20 minutes or
so of being in an hour four hours
probably the longest I've ever taken was
you know six or seven hours so how to
get into the dream
dimension in Minecraft there's no dream
Dimension maybe there's a mod that has a
dream Dimension or something but I want
to know the answer to that question so
I'll have to have Mojang employee help
come up here or something but
how tall is dream Minecraft can I stand
can I stand up is that
I like to say that I'm six foot two
so I'm six foot two I think in shoes I'm
six foot three
how old is your Minecraft August 12th is
my birthday I just turned 24 years old
1999.
how did dream get famous I quit my job
when I had no subscribers and I posted
my first video July of 2019 so I tried
to treat it like a job I was like all
right well if I actually want to make it
a job then I need to treat it like a job
so I put you know you know at least
eight plus hours a day every day into it
for a long time I studied I planned I
came up with ideas and tried different
things I spent like every week an hour
for months and months and months just
editing and recording and coming with
ideas and there's a little bit of luck
and a little bit of um skill and a
little bit of um you know a little bit
of everything kind of mixed in together
how did dream and sapnap meet we met on
a server called the MCPVP it's a
Minecraft uh player versus player server
that you would play like there was
Hunger Games and you would fight other
players in it because it was The Hunger
Games you can make teams and he typed in
chat type one two three if you want a
Skype team and I replied and said one
two three and we were friends ever since
and now we lived together 10 years later
so how
did Dream escape the prison I was uh
broken out by the one and only
technoblade it's funny because like
behind the scenes like me and awesome
dude work together on that prison it was
our baby we came up with all the like
mechanics and the Redstone and all the
all the different ways like no we're
having it like suspended in lava and
you're not going to be able to it's
impenetrable prison and then technoblade
of course comes around and just test out
outsmart me even though he was saving me
in the actual lore
what does dream play Minecraft on I play
Minecraft on PC I guess you can
technically play Minecraft on almost
anything your phone Xbox I like more
control and you can aim better and stuff
in my opinion so I like the PC what is
dreams
fov and Minecraft so fov stands for
field of view and it's like how zoomed
in your screen is I guess when you're
playing mine is 90. why is it 90 I don't
know it's just my preference so I just
messed with it and then all my friends
have it as 90 now because we agreed when
we were making videos we were like let's
keep it consistent so if you're watching
everybody's perspective you can see all
the same Zoom I guess so there you go
don't be like me make a 90. what version
of Minecraft does dream play on I play
on the latest version of Minecraft I
used to only play on like 1.8 and 1.7
which were older versions of Minecraft
and then I actually realized that most
of the world other than like multiplayer
servers play on the latest version and
so I was like I want to get more views
on my videos I probably should play on
the one that most people play on what is
dreams this is a long one fastest
Minecraft speed run I don't know I mean
I know like it probably in my videos
you're talking about like a Manhunt the
quickest I ever did a Manhunt like
against my friends which is a series I
do where I'm I'm like speed running and
I have my friends trying to stop me I
think I'd probably say it's probably
about an hour 45 or something if I'm
just talking about with like three or
four players chasing me and then by
myself I think it's around uh like 20
minutes what is clay dreams last name
that is a secret we do not speak of that
why is dream so good at Minecraft I
think it's a lot of practice I've played
Minecraft since I was literally 11 years
old and I've put in hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of hours into the
game and played way too much Minecraft
way more than I wanted to admit why did
dream
quit Minecraft I didn't quit Minecraft I
am doing a little bit less Minecraft
recently because I've been making music
and doing other things definitely didn't
quit and I don't think I ever really
will because it's a Sandbox so you can
pretty much do whatever you want so I
can I can never really get bored of it
why does dream have a crown Minecraft
that is very heartwarming I don't I'm
surprised that's a Google result I
actually just recently removed the crown
from my Minecraft skin I put it on after
um technoblade who is a another friend
of mine and a Minecraft YouTuber that
passed away he had a crown on his skin
and I I wanted to put it on my skin to
honor him
um and then I just recently published a
tribute related to him and I thought
that it was worthy to retire the crown
it had been a year you know give it back
to him because he's still you know he
did he did beat me so
dream Minecraft Guinness World Records I
have two of them I have a Guinness world
record for the most subscribers for a
dedicated Minecraft YouTube channel I
got when I had 29 million 9000 900 and I
was like no so they gave me a new one on
the dot at 30 million 30 million
dedicated microfuture with my
subscribers I have the most viewed
Minecraft gameplay video I think I got
it when I was at 103 million or
something views there's my two Guinness
world and they're hanging on my wall so
did dream
win a streamy yes I have one
three streamies I just won one in person
for the first time for gamer of the year
I think I've won gamer of the year three
of the last five years which is very
cool I love the Streamys thank you
streamings here's a long one dream
Minecraft versus five Hunters I did a
series called Minecraft Manhunt where I
tried to speedrun Minecraft and my
friends tried to stop me and I just
added more people I did like a little
you know series of kind of like you know
the NBA finals or something like sports
where it's like you do best of three or
best of five five hundreds was the final
one the videos are getting tens of
millions of views 30 40 50 60 70 million
views and I was like let's end it when
we're at top when we're on top and let's
let's end it with a bang it's the 500's
Grand Finale was the final video in
Manhunt series might do a reunion one at
some point but at this point it's
already been I think over a year since
the last um our dreams Minecraft Manhunt
scripted no they're not but there's a
lot of things that definitely can that
that people would be like oh that's
that's like kind of scripting in a way
we have like certain rules that make it
more fair but also make it more
interesting for the viewer and then I
also do a lot of little editing tricks
so a lot of times if like we're
recording and I've already done a trick
or something I have the audio recording
from when I did that trick the first
time and so that will be in the video
that way the viewers experience is the
same as the hunters was the original
time dream
Minecraft friends my biggest friends are
all the ones on my YouTube channel you
know George's not found in sapnap are my
two best friends um but other than that
I mean yeah bad boy Halo and Aunt Frost
an awesome dude are three of my good
friends they're in my YouTube videos
most of my friends I feel like that I'm
closest with are my friends that I
played Minecraft with since I was like
10 and we were all like friends before
we were YouTubers and then we became
YouTubers together
dream
Minecraft Unsolved Mysteries that's a
series I did on my uh my channel a while
back where I just did like kind of a You
Know parody of BuzzFeed in a way where I
did like little mysteries in Minecraft I
was like you know did did PewDiePie like
revive his dog and and lie about it in
his video or like why is Mojang not
adding sharks like his silly little
things but make him interesting and
dramatic and that's kind of my my Flair
has always been it's kind of you know
dramatizing things and making them kind
of movie-like and interesting but it's
still there you can go watch it dream
Minecraft bed Wars I'm pretty decent I'm
not I'm definitely not you know great uh
at it uh you you really need like a lot
of there's some people that are crazy at
it I guess in that instance I'm not a
Minecraft god dream
Minecraft Enemy song I've done like
little little song parodies like I sang
like under the tree instead of under the
sea and stuff so I might have done
something like that in a video that
people were like oh I want that I mean
none of my songs are about Minecraft or
have Minecraft enemies so that's a
mystery I guess dream Minecraft tour I
am actually on a tour right now I'm
currently doing a Music Tour where I'm
going to a bunch of places Show's been
going great yeah I mean just was in DC
the other night out of New York
improving each time so practice makes
perfect
this was dream and that was really
interesting a lot of them were very like
insightful and I guess it was a couple
of heartwarming ones that I would not
have expected you know from Google
results so that's it for now